[Applaudissements]
[Rires]
[Musique]
dans ce cas collaboration cas
l'animateur est pour toi la peep la pire
pompe à vélo de la télévision y en a il
y en a un nom il y en a il ya là
plusieurs mains choix est difficile
ouais après moi ce que parce que j'aime
passer les hypocrites les mecs quand la
langue de bois tout ça et c'est vrai que
sur ces 8 quelle joie mais jamais
castaldi faire des trucs un peu je
trouve qu'il n'est pas direct tu vois on
va s'en va le dira aux téléspectateurs
on s'entend super bien
donc j'ai envie qu'on se classe 1 to
franchement une semaine qui dit derby 1
qui va franchement avec moi tu te gêne
pas vincent est ce que tu étais content
d'être avec nous moi je t'avoue kalabane
je voulais c'est avoue qu'à la base je
voulais recevoir sébastien chabal c'est
vrai ouais aussi je rigolais au grand
journal mais bon moscato complètement
jojo et tu en avais marre de tous les
mecs qui disaient ouais moi je connais
johnny c'est pour me tape un spectacle
raconte moi c'est rigolade ben ouais
autres moi j'ai été élevée comme tout
nous tous dans le truc de coluche tout
le monde connaît connu la bonne mais n'y
a pas un mec sur un plateau qui dit
qu'il connaît pas coluche
ouais les mecs ils balancent des phrases
moi je me souviens de coluche m'avait
dit codol tu connais rien du tout
grosso siffleur tu racontes des six mois
je me suis je vais faire pareil avec
jolie j'ai croisé deux fois je veux dire
que je le connais ça mange pas de pain
ils sont un plateau gt michel michel
drucker john et une fois je veux dire tu
parles de johnny même un chef faute sur
tarn jean michel douat va choper nous
tous spectacles à la con c'est bien le
cas de le dire c'est un spectacle à la
cause parle énormément de poids iem
passage à une équipe de bras cassés
je prends le toit mais c'est ce que tu
m'as dit et je parle pas
c'est dans une position où on m'a dit
alors c'est sébastien tôt comment ça se
passe je lui ai dit si tu rigole pas du
bluff ou dans la gueule du riche
vincent moscato cyril et doc gynéco qui
se retrouvent dans la jungle qui tombe
sur une tribu un peu style et les
latrines musicale photo epa moscato
moscato voilà et la tribu re div pour
vous sauver il faut que vous alliez
chacun récupérer son fruit chacun
[Applaudissements]
quelle émission ne vaut pas un péché
titre ne viole pas la vilotte je ne sais
pas mais c'est très mignon c'est du
divertissement
c'est vrai zito prix au premier nommé
après la conversation a pu boxer n'est
pas de la shoah à l'époque déchets qui
reçoit ces chéquiers et il les prend et
demande aux banquiers plusieurs
chéquiers alors il va faire des courses
partout il va chez conforama chez but
j'étais coincé chez ea dit et tout est
bon sens y ait la paix les devises il
dit c'est une marque de vêtements de
lunettes
alors en fait ils ils achètent tous
partout il va chez merco chez renault ou
chez peugeot et son banquier la paix le
10 mai moscato tôt tu as découvert
moscato il dit c'est pas grave je vous
fais un chèque
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
quatre sportifs et pour vous
actuellement le plus gros flots mireille
offrirait alors je me sorti je me
souviens d'une sortie fracassante sur
ibrahimovic
non mais c'est vrai parce que parce que
je trouvais que que ce mec c'était idée
marketing bien sûr que c'est un bon
joueur tout ça mais c'est le déplacement
d'une tonne de tondeuses à gazon une 300
mètres par parma qui faisait toi qui
régnait docteur et le mec qui sortait
avais tu te jure il montait à 110 120 au
taquet le faux les mantas en 32 l'ont
arrêté alors tu joues le soir de la
saint valentin c'est parce que t'as pas
de bond est ce que tu veux te sentir
moins seul c'est vrai que j'ai passé un
moment s'en sert pas la fontaine
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
célibataire à quelle animatrice ou
chroniqueuse j'aurais bien donner un
coup de canif comme vous dites halal os
ou un animateur on sait pas oui mais
matthieu delormeau
[Applaudissements]
[Rires]
patiente a fait une carrière de rugbyman
pourquoi avoir choisi un sport de
gonzesses pas vu commenté cyrille cadre
qu'est ce qu'un homme était épais comme
un pic à bigorneaux
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
il m'a vu il m'a vu il m'a vu en slip en
plus on est à 1 on a passé à l'ombre moi
ça s'est joué à rien je suis quand même
et on vous le dit on a passé un long
moment si ce n'est pas la fin chez
patrick sébastien
alors voilà c'est pour finir je tiens à
te féliciter pour ta carrière
vraiment vincent elle est vraiment
magnifique parce que franchement avec ta
gueule c'était pas gagné quand même
merci de me parler d'abord de ma
carrière parce que c'est très gentil de
tapas et la tienne et commence quand
[Applaudissements]
m
[Musique]